nadège bons joueurs le président
français manuel macron devait se rendre
dans la capitale autrichienne mais
finalement il annuler son voyage tout à
fait à venir alors il avait été annoncée
hier soir par le gouvernement autrichien
le déplacement à des manuels macron à
vienne ici en autriche n'aura finalement
pas lieu
sa rencontre avec sebastian course le
chancelier autrichien se fera finalement
par visioconférence en début de semaine
c'est ce qu'annonce ce matin l'elysée à
la présidence de la république française
précise que cette modification est due à
des questions d'agenda a liés à la
gestion de la crise sanitaire alors les
deux hommes devraient évoquer ensemble
la lutte contre le terrorisme et
l'islamisme radical
assis à vienne l'autriche continue de
pleurer ses morts trois jours après
cette attaque terroriste qui a fait
quatre morts et une vingtaine de blessés
une marche en hommage aux victimes
elle doit d'ailleurs avoir lieu cet
après midi à 15h30
les organisateurs appellent les
autorités autrichiennes à prendre les
mesures nécessaires pour éviter qu'une
tragédie de ce type se reproduise à
l'avenir
nadège à remercier beaucoup pour toutes
ces précisions